[Music]
how in the world did our nation's
economic advisors go from ridiculing
tariffs and subsidies trade
protectionism would be one of the
stupidest things we could possibly do it
was one of the causes of the Great
Depression - promoting pure
protectionism the steel industry must be
kept aloft despite the fact that it's
always getting up you know what I would
do I would subsidize the answer lies in
the paradigm shifting reality distorting
and frequently cringe-inducing power of
power itself by fellow Americans it's
sometimes said that if you put three
economists together in a room and ask
them a question you're liable to get
more than three answers this is the sad
story of a team of presidential advisors
with two opinions for every man before
Trump took office they stood for a
principle that conservatives at least
rhetorically have championed for decades
free and fair trade brings growth and
opportunity and creates jobs and they
all warn that high trade barriers what
is often called protectionism undermines
economic growth and destroys jobs
following in this tradition was Mike
Pence you can see that our existing
trade agreements have truly benefitted
Indiana and the entire United States as
a member of the House of Representatives
pence voted to normalize trade relations
with China he praised NAFTA voted for
the Central American Free Trade
Agreement supported the trans-pacific
partnership and backed free trade
agreements with Australia Singapore
Chile and Peru I did not come to
Washington asked working Americans to
subsidize the bad decisions of corporate
America even though pence represented a
state with over a hundred thousand auto
workers he voted against then President
Obama's corporate bailouts out of
principle
Donald Trump will choose Indiana
Governor Mike Pence to be his running
mate after joining team Trump hence was
a changed man rescued from an unpopular
governorship pence was thrust into the
national spotlight and his political
career was given a new life his
conversion to protectionism was so
sudden and complete he had a hard time
convincing journalists his new faith was
sincere so are you for the 35% Tara let
me go back to the intervening part are
you for the terror though I'm the
carrier they well I I'm for us putting
everything on the table in negotiations
in renegotiating NAFTA you're supporting
the trans-pacific partnership that mr.
Trump says would rape this country as
pence hit the talkshow circuit we
learned that every free trade agreement
he had supported his entire political
career was now a bad deal and up for
renegotiation I support free trade and
so does Donald Trump the United States
under successive administration's have
been negotiating really bad trade deals
and it's month before he was sworn in
his vice president pence went from
bad-mouthing banking bailouts to
bankrolling the carrier corporation in
his home state just one year after
supporting free trade with China he now
declared it enemy number one China is
not an ally China is an adversary of the
United States at about the same time
Trump's campaign adviser Stephen Moore
and White House chief of staff
Reince Priebus we're stressing key
elements of protection in their speeches
and public appearances companies who
want to send them abroad accountable we
should not have free trade with China if
they're gonna continue to steal five
hundred billion dollars a year from us
right Moore told a group of top
Republicans that the GOP was no longer
the party of Ronald Reagan
I used to be a free trader the political
reality is there's a backlash against
tray whether we like it or not we better
adopt the rules in ways that benefit
American workers more or free trade is
not going to flourish the bedrock
underneath the Republican Party is
shifting at the rate of one presidential
advisor at a time after a year in office
members of trumps economic team have
either adopted the commander-in-chief's
line own trade tariffs are important to
preserve the steel industry kept a low
profile or have resigned this is Gary
cones last meeting in the cabinet of the
cabinet and he's been terrific he may be
a globalist but I still like him as the
United States follows other countries
down the path of economic nationalism
advocates for free trade are losing
their voice fewer are making a
compelling public case for free trade as
Milton Friedman did for decades
you know let's suppose three of us are
out in a boat in the ocean and one of
the fellas in there takes out a gun and
shoots holes in the bottom of the boat
is it the sensible thing for the others
of us to do to take out our guns and
shoot more holes in the bottom of the
boat that's kind of a silly notion isn't
it but yet that is exactly the notion of
protection and retaliation which are the
same arguments that more Priebus Kudlow
and vice president Pence all made before
joining team Trump and as Ronald Reagan
believed only inconsistently during the
1980s this legislation will enable us to
enforce steel export restraints guard
against unfair import surges into the
American market and help keep the United
States from becoming the world's steel
dump
although NAFTA and the precursor to the
World Trade Organization were born from
his administration Reagan also raised a
punitive 100 percent tariff on Japanese
electronics a forty five percent tariff
on Japanese motorcycles he slapped
export quotas on cars and machine tools
and Canadian lumber and sugar just
enough economic nationalism to make our
current protectionist and chief proud
frankly I loved his style his attitude
he was a great cheerleader for our
country you know for the country but not
great on the train all of which is to
say maybe President Trump is more
Reaganesque than even he gives himself
credit for